it's it's offense versus defense I want
the government to help me I'm in big
trouble I'm scared
meanwhile I'm took a triathlon Bucky in
my bike in my [ __ ] house two guys me
another [ __ ] month
you got your perspective
[Applause]
[Music]
morning everybody tea time is tea time I
think you should have a tea comes on tea
time would be time anyway
good good morning good morning on this
beautiful Wednesday we've got two hours
of Q&A if you if you want to ask your
questions to 1 2 9 3 1 5 7 3 1 text me
your question I'm really excited to be
on with you guys the last two days have
been pretty remarkable and done a little
bit of oolong tea and a whole lot of
love
and a couple of good opinions
observations and hypotheses in my head
so without further ado Dustin let's get
this train moving first one that was
coming up there's Brian vine you're on
hey brother good to see you what's
cooking I was gonna wear my Phillies hat
this morning I'm glad I didn't don't
want didn't want to deal with that kinda
like honestly I'm a humongous Philly fan
like I we both hate the we both hate the
Giants
I think Philly is rugged and real in a
lot of ways I think Philly is more New
York than New York in a lot of ways I'm
about Philly
the Eagles don't follow me the Knicks
haven't been good enough for the Sixers
to bother me they have a big good either
and even though I'm raising my little
guy a man's fan because of his cousins
yeah I grew up a Yankee fan so I don't
have I don't have that passion against
the Phillies Plus on the Bryce Harper so
anyway what's good it's good to amend so
obviously you know you kind of know
where we're at you know the architecture
the visualization or construction side
of things why don't you tell people
because obviously we know just yeah some
cause but help everybody understand what
yeah yeah sure so you know I run a
company called design buns based here in
Philadelphia we help people take the
virtual world and turn it into the
physical world you know in house we have
an architecture department a 3d
visualization of mark
team that creates 3d renderings
animations for people around the nation
to help resale and pre lease real estate
and then we also physically build
construction and do a lot of that
design-build here in Philadelphia and
around the Greater area obviously with
the shutdown and everything you know
it's kind of affecting multiple facets
but more than anything it's affected the
construction side you know unfortunately
had to lay off about ten percent of my
staff on that realm yeah but but
fortunately for us you know the the
architecture and visualization side are
continuing to to continue we're signing
contracts we're still bringing money
through the door but one of the issues
that just seems to be kind of plaguing
my organization right now is this new
adaption to the work from home life you
know everyone's you know into that you
know architects you know everyone's
collaborating typically side by side and
now everyone's like kind of feeling the
woes from just being away from each
other so I you know obviously I know you
have a thousand people I mean we're
doing a lot I mean one of the phone
calls from leadership was people are
burnt out and like burnt out like we
have a little like but but as you dig
under the hood people have their kids at
home so that's making them stressful you
know I am a collaborator by nature like
Tim Garrity sits on top of itself right
outside my office cuz I love that [ __ ] I
think you know Brett I'll tell you I
think one of the things leaders have to
do and CEOs have to do during this time
whether you have one employee when we
have 30 employees when you have a
thousand place is recognize that it's
not a long period of time
like I'm not crippled by the notion of
Team Gary so I'm gonna Andy yesterday he
once in Gary and so you know and we
talked about some stuff recently I'm
kind of weary okay if they're not
productive for 90 days
like I I go into it's on my shoulders
like I'm sitting all day yesterday for
12 hours going through costs that don't
affect people's salaries and jobs good
things for me everything to put us in a
place where I feel like I work for our
employees during this crisis they don't
work for me and so for you you have a
small company right like how many people
again well note one
now perfect so I would talk to all what
I would do if I were you is I'd call all
28 and be like hey I know Pam that you
love sitting next to Cindy do you guys
collaborate that way try to do it on
zoom if you can't don't don't overly
beat yourself up if it's a 8 out of 10
this time because you're the kind of
person that loves to collaborate that's
how you don't over judge yourself don't
worry about for like my big thing is
like crying over spilled tea is a
complete [ __ ] waste of time
like the corona virus is here we're not
sitting together the end so some
realistic compassion is how I would
attack it okay no I like that it just is
what a [ __ ] is yeah it's it's yeah we
keep going at the new norm for now I
mean you know my people are getting
that's where people are [ __ ] it up
it's it's it's the new temporary norm
okay and like some people are hearing
the new normal and they're like like
this is back to patients this is gonna
be point 0:04 percent of most people's
life this time like this is a [ __ ]
blip this is like a non-productive you
made a bunch of [ __ ] bad decisions
six months like the amount of six-month
periods I've had in my business is the
last 22 years that's suck [ __ ] cuz I
made a bad decision twelve months
earlier and the concept or the strategy
did like this ain't [ __ ] this is like
make them happy right make them [ __ ]
happy be like yeah you can't sit next to
Pam and shoot the [ __ ] make the work
better but pretty cool to like actually
have more downtime than people think cuz
you don't know what your absent you know
like to like to go there yeah okay kind
of related to that how you know to kind
of two questions in one are you looking
if at any for government indicators for
how long this is gonna last or how long
do you I don't typically think this is
gonna you know in your gut how long do
you think we have in my skyress
environment in my gut in this
environment of like actually not being
physically together yeah four to eight
weeks the RAM of you know this two
trillion dollar package that got passed
last night like I'm not sure what the
quote-unquote ramifications are here's
what I can tell you and
you've been and you know this I've been
talking about this a long time a lot of
entrepreneurs haven't been during a time
they got punched in the face here we go
and the question is bro like do you get
up or do you lay there and get counted
out like it's not super complicated to
your point some of your business is
working but like you know look if people
stop building because you know
construction all building goes down that
will affect you and guess what you'll
then convert your virtual software to
[ __ ] like something else like org or
you'll cry fold and and work somewhere
it's not super complicated what I and I
actually want entrepreneurs to not
demonize the step backwards to work so I
think this could be the greatest era of
fake or over-leveraged for first time
entrepreneurs that got caught then say
[ __ ] then strategically get a job for
two or three years where they know
there's like you know right if I said to
you bad news you have to get a job
entrepreneur is illegal in America but
it's gonna be legal in three years but
you have to get a job you would say okay
let me get a job that rounds out some of
my skills or let me find a mentor or
somebody I look up to or something of
that nature that I can learn from I
think that might actually happen to some
entrepreneurs and I'm telling all the
entrepreneurs out there or that or that
not not the best versions of the
entrepreneur self the first time around
maybe use this moment to take a step
back to go and get a job and work for
somebody that you admire work for Nancy
because you look up to her ability as
this said that learn for two years
swallow that humility pill and come back
in twenty twenty two more prepared than
ever so there's gonna be a lot of
there's nothing but opportunity bro no I
appreciate that and one of my favorite
things you said yes it was
entrepreneurship school and for the
money dries up it's right all right
today so I'm sure thank you brother
yep Thank You hos Dustin are you asking
me to do something here yeah just the
video got turned off
hey guy you turned it off accident yeah
switched all the way I'm sure I was just
off the air for three seconds that was
Dustin Lisa I just want everybody no big
shout out to everybody's watching on
Twitter and tic toc and IG I know my
team is holding up their phones to the
screen right now so I appreciate that
for all of you who are watching on other
platforms and Facebook's two one two
nine three one five seven three one
just text me that is my community app
texting platform where I do one-on-one
texting and book messaging for
inspiration and opportunity and that is
where we are taking the questions from
you'll be contacted by one of my team
today tomorrow as we keep doing tea with
Gary B and get you on this soon so let's
go to the next one what he got Destin
got Ashley
yep hi Gary good morning morning yes how
are you good how are you I'm super well
good I'm in California so like you were
in the lockdown and I own a small
branding and marketing agency half of my
clients are doing what your advice has
been like creating content using this
time to lean out unnecessary expenses
but then I have a small segment of
creatives like photographers you know
makeup artists and you know guitar
teachers that don't necessarily have the
audience to create an online course or
do anything online with clips at this
time is there any advice that you can
give them or give me to help support
them during this time to get the sales
and for this next four 800 weeks now for
some of them it's for some of them it's
hey we find you to build a [ __ ]
community on the internet you didn't
think that something like this could
happen
here we the [ __ ] are but instead of
saying wham anywhere or [ __ ] you or I'm
sorry or sorry no crying in baseball
they need to get they need to
immediately start a tick-tock and
Linkedin and YouTube and podcast they
they it what they're gonna do right now
is dwell right now now could they go on
Instagram live
perform on the guitar and ask for tips
they're gonna have to ask for they're
gonna have to ask for handouts
they don't have an audience to sell to
and then they start by trying to sell to
everybody right away you know they're
not gonna convert very high and they're
gonna ruin their brand in perpetuity now
one can say [ __ ] my brand I have no
money so to that point actually if they
want to make a course or eBook
they're more than welcome I'm a very bad
feeling it's not gonna do very well
right
I'd rather than put on three concerts on
IG TV and ask for donations like a
telethon I think that you could see that
I think there's people connection I mean
I've been doing I mean I bought [ __ ]
a bunch of [ __ ] honey yesterday and
like I've been buying tens of thousands
of masks and so like I there's a lot of
compassion out there from people who can
help and so I think a free concert on IG
TV with literally a telethon when they
throw up there I would set up a Ben
though I would tend the I would here's
what I would sorry so I was saying he do
they answer that like I'll give you that
the actual answer what can be done that
might help them and then in parallel
what I'd like them to do right they're
in dire dire straits
they started IG TV they they great
creative venmo they test they post what
their account the Ben mo username this
is my been mo any donations if you feel
compelled to any donations to my been mo
and then use your name in it then they
pin it right you know what I'm talking
about right yeah and then they put on a
[ __ ] 8 hour concert and then in
between songs they're like by the way I
think all seven keys are small right
thank all seven of you you know that
actually let's go through the whole
process then they post on her Facebook
and their email and they text every
single person this is not a joke I have
text every single person your phone with
the URL to your Instagram and saying if
you could please follow me it would mean
the world I need to build this during
this time so now all of a sudden you've
got 137 means 4,000 names in your in
your phone number you text all of them
you convert 10% of them let's say 1800s
you send a post on your dormant Facebook
post to your Instagram you emailed your
entire address list and now all of a
sudden miraculously just asking you've
got 383 people then you go live of those
383 on Instagram you know 29 watch you
right but here's what's fun out of the
29 that watch you one is a person in
your phone that you knew in college but
you don't even really know that well but
they decided to tune in because
everybody's [ __ ] bored that person
actually currently happens to work for
ABC News in Charlotte and decides to
take a photo of you being on Instagram
live and write a story which then leads
to huge exposure for you which then
leads to you having a bigger audience
which then leads to more people donating
a week from now because I'm doing teen
with Gary D I mean there's a chance that
this Q&A show team Gary Vee becomes like
a syndicated national show for me and
that becomes my destiny all because of
this there's a lot of good an
opportunity that come for them so a
first accountability like sorry bucko
you should have [ __ ] been doing this
because I want them to do it post this
then number two you give me the advice I
just gave you
okay that's great there's a lot of
people right now who should be doing
telethons with pinned venmo accounts
doing stand-up comedy playing
entertaining kids with puppet shows that
can make a ton of money because there's
a lot of parents of wealth who saved
money we've got a lot of people whether
parents or their parents or their
children that they need to entertain in
a small corridor of their home right now
and nothing would make them happier than
to throw up a live and and when they
walk by they're like like literally in
this setting of TV watching watching I'm
on my phone I see it on my pocket this
guy's do me a huge favor here's a $50
donation to your mo I think we just made
a ton of people a ton of money that
needed it bad
the problem is ash that was one of the
better peace advices that I've given in
my career it's a great idea for the
coronavirus right now and still
ninety-five percent of the people that
are watching right now or when they clip
this tomorrow for Instagram that need to
do it right because people are worried
about judgement they're too proud to ask
the donation
that I probably have a little bit of
that in me they're too scared to do it
on video they don't like to have their
makeup looks like I just encourage
everybody to do things during this time
that make you uncomfortable this whole
thing in the macro is uncomfortable this
is the time to practice getting
uncomfortable the ability to be
uncomfortable but be practical is one of
the most important capabilities of an
entrepreneur and a leader I agree and
what's your advice though because that's
even when times are good people are
still uncomfortable to to ask for the
sales to market their business which is
why I mean why you give it away and most
people don't execute what can you say to
those people to help them maybe you
finally get that tipping point to go and
execute this stuff right now
no realizing they have no choice that's
what's good about times like this one
number two stop worrying about other
people's [ __ ] opinion like I you know
this is why I pound people the only
reason people don't post and don't make
is cuz they're insecure mm-hmm yet
you're worried what your mom's gonna
think your brother's gonna think your
best friend's gonna think you think
you've gained 15 pounds you think you
don't good look with makeup you think
that you're balding you think that you
are dumb you think who the [ __ ] gonna
care
like people care we we're [ __ ] knows
he's [ __ ] everybody cares about
everything
go [ __ ] me thank you so much okay big
shout-out to dr. tehran khan and twitter
by the way everybody please actually
let's a quick stop everybody right now
please tweet this share this share this
on Facebook share this on your Instagram
like take a screenshot if you're on
Instagram and post it if you're on
Twitter right now please post I just
retweeted dr. tehran khan who's got a
nice little picture up there
it's time to get tea with gary be out
there to the masses that's going to
scream go and what's good sky so I'm
from Jersey like you I'm a college
student this came back from being kicked
out of school because of the quarantine
and everything
my family owns a small gym in a mob
County and we were dealing with part you
know keyboard/mouse County I know yeah
so we're dealing with the gym being
closed now because of the mandate and so
my dad and I I'm trying to innovate in
two online classes for the classes that
he has or a big classes but the general
members who come in we want we're
worried about retaining them and making
sure that all those new members still
are engaged with our platform and are
still here so how where's your advice on
maintain that and be able to facilitate
their needs that we can't really
facilitate if they're I climbed to take
classes with us online understand a
couple things one first of all you're
really good looking dude I needed to say
that good jobs guy number two and a good
smile number two first thing I would do
if I was kind of other son in this
family I would say sky dad we need to
call every customer we need to sit here
and call every customer and say how are
you doing
we miss you just wanted you to like I
would call every customer engagement
doesn't just come in the utility of what
your gym provided with a physical
location and weights and an exercise
equipment I think if you were to call
all 5500 5,000 I don't know how many
members are over this next week and just
I'm just checking in on you how's your
health and fitness you know we love you
jerseys [ __ ] strong that's not what
we got this but through 9/11 with
through other [ __ ] hey I think you'd
find 25 percent of them that would have
never considered doing online stuff
because they wouldn't have found you on
Instagram or YouTube or Facebook might
in that conversation and you're looking
for it when you're talking to them say
oh I'd love to FaceTime in for a class
of just push-ups and things of that
nature right like I'm virtually working
out right now with my trainer Mike and
I'm like on my [ __ ] chair and then
you know what I mean yeah there's
there's a lot you can do there's the
ability for you guys if you financially
are sound and enough like for example
Wine Library I'm talking about with this
yesterday we have food in the gourmet
Department you know that is is probably
in a month
so gonna go spoiled right so what we're
doing right now is going through all our
best local customers putting together 25
and 50 dollar food baskets and just
sending it to them yeah not even trying
to sell it to them you know one of the
things you guys could do is there might
be a twelve dollar twenty-five dollar
weight dumbbell something that you guys
believe in or like maybe you call that
supplier or even buy it or reach out to
50 of them and say hey can you ship this
to my 450 members I'll pay you half
price for it or they'll say [ __ ] you
business is booming and you'll be like
okay I'll you just decide to buy it you
decide that it's worth $12 a user to
keep them got it here this is a time
when you have to spend this is where
every business owner is gonna make a
mistake this is the time business owners
need to spend more money on keeping
their customers if they can not
everybody's in that position but money
comes in a lot of form money comes in
the form of of inventory you're sitting
on right you know it comes in the form
of spoiled inventory for food people so
I would just innovate with come with
deep one-to-one hand-to-hand combat on
calls yeah try to convert some of those
people like I hated the idea of working
from home and I'm in day three and I'm
getting used to it so some of them might
like virtually working out and then
number three drug stuff like actually
maybe sending weights to their house and
like and that cup this is the time to
double down on your customer not beg
them to support you if you can afford it
a lot of times that's not just money
sitting in the bank that's with
inventory and things sitting in your
business yeah my dad kind of did that a
little bit with the clients that you
have classes so he let them come in sign
out like a kettle bell and like I'm a
dumbbell to like work out and we could
like you like dynamic workouts that's
amazing so I've like seen this
opportunity to like really build that
online status Kaiser Hall call customer
yeah I'm telling you it's a big idea
definitely I want to definitely share
though him I really appreciate that
machine though does another thing real
quick so as a college student being home
you know everything's very uncertain in
next like couple months and
looking at like internships in the
summer should I just like you know
badger people a bit like because I want
to be insensitive and be like you know
networking and everything I I think it's
a great listen I'll be honest with you
like full transparency like vaynermedia
business I'm looking at the internship
program for a banner this year and
possibly not doing it because I have to
save every job that I possibly can and
they're losing revenue because of Corona
and so I what I would say is I would put
out content on Instagram and LinkedIn
and again if you don't have a LinkedIn
account you just create one and you just
post why you're gonna crush internships
summer 2020 and you talk about like
everyone's gonna be pent up and I'm a
social dude and I can't wait to like you
know I I think I think I think making
content versus begging and pleading I
think going offense and saying why you
can versus hoping or or desperation is
always the answer so what I would say is
I think you should be on pants on fire
but I don't think that should be in the
form of like you know please if you have
anything else I think any comes in the
form of you making videos and written
posts about why you're gonna be the
greatest single intern of the summer of
2020 and that going viral or catching
one person's eye that's how I think [ __ ]
works okay
you know all these [ __ ] rugged
entrepreneurs that I knew like [ __ ]
thought they were [ __ ] big shots have
been [ __ ] DMing me like yo do you
know anybody in the government that we
need a bailout I'm like you know you
know what I mean like why why not why
not all take a step back like maybe you
need to sell your [ __ ] Mercedes and
[ __ ] take the bus like facts there's
a [ __ ] big shot because they raised
capital and they were burning more money
than the making or because they had
loans or their massive debt everybody
[ __ ] wanted a front on Instagram so
much or claim they're so [ __ ] rich
instead of actually do
and loving it [ __ ] it's true the
truth super true I talk to you bro
doctor let's [ __ ] tea time
a lot of [ __ ] capitalists buddies of
mine guys and gals thinking they're
tough guys and gals now I want the
government to bail them out because they
didn't say the [ __ ] penny that a man
manage your cash flow I see people
sharing big shout-out to Colleen
Costello big shout-out to rush candy and
big shout-out to Sonia really appreciate
everybody sharing please share share and
real quick one little fun one big
shout-out is just talking about the
gourmet food anybody who's watching
yummy Tex calm another insight please
sign up for wine text or yummy text
yummy why um my text wine text sign up
for my dad's text service programs kind
of like Groupon for me food and wine but
hey I want to help my dad and I and the
deals are ridiculous and I know people
are getting delivered wine and food but
more importantly I think a lot of you
should start text platforms for your
businesses it's been crushing for us
Olivia what's good hey how are you I'm
well how are you I'm great this is
really awesome for me I've been
following you for at least six years now
so big influence and all my stuff it's
insane right now
but I really wanted to talk to you
because I'm I've been working for a lot
of years kind of slowly building up what
I wanted to do I know that I really
wanted to work with people you know
emotionally physically mentally my
degree is in psychology was working on
you know my masters in support the
performance psychology but I'm a
personal trainer I'm a dancer
choreographer and I you know
subconsciously knew what I wanted to do
but I was finding different ways like
how do I really want to bring this
together and this year this past year I
was like it kind of clicked to me
exactly what I wanted to do and so I'm
really bringing together I want to kind
of have a major platform and have like
subdivisions of what I do instead of
like outside sourcing but to refer back
to myself
so whether it's like for my massage
therapy whether it's for personal
training for you know dance training
stuff like that but my question was
mostly um do you think it would be best
to kind of continue the training that
I'm doing now continued like the dance
classes that I have now and then as I
get my new certifications and licenses
just kind of folding everything in layer
by layer or do you see it as okay gotcha
let me kind of like let me tell you
something you're charismatic and a great
communicator and so like how much
content are you making I'm literally
right now cleaning everything that I
have starting not even from scratch but
really I decided my you know tick
tocking and I was posting you know
videos yesterday that I literally just
started like my real tick-tock I was
doing what she said I was watching I was
learning and kind of absorbing what
people were doing so I'm revamping all
of my social media right now and
literally cleaning and when you say
revamping she'd straight with me Olivia
when you say revamping like were you
just bullshitting like just not posting
enough yeah I wasn't posting enough why
why somebody who follows Gary Vee for
six years somebody who has this kind of
charisma has [ __ ] dimples like why
are we you know why are we not posting
tell me the [ __ ] truth go real with
me because here's the two things that
worry me and excite me if you're
following me for six years and I've been
consistent as [ __ ] about and you're this
good on camera naturally and have this
kind of articulation and kind of like
flow and just like I like like you
within two seconds right why like that
warm smile like tell me the truth now
why the [ __ ] are you not posting 12
times a day that was honestly just
myself getting to myself 100% I was
overthinking overanalyzing whose
feedback are you more scared of in this
poll hey anonymous people saying you're
ugly you're stupid you're dumb be having
low numbers so when somebody sees that
you only have 313 followers you thought
that that would position you poorly and
they wouldn't pay for your thing or see
family that just you know parents or
or whoever your most loved ones are that
may just judge ABC all of them be CBA
ABC a just be what honestly it was more
so being there's only the constant yeah
honestly was more nervous about putting
out content that I was prejudging like
even if I give it was like dance video
if I didn't feel like it was up to par
of what I really could do when I mess
something up then I was like I don't
want somebody to see this and prejudge
off of one video and then because and
that was me and because you and let's
talk to screw because you knew that
ultimately you wanted them to pay you
for something and thus if there's
something wrong there it made you
vulnerable for them not to have
confidence at paying you so like when
I'm in person I have no problem with
portraying my intent and what I really
believe my who I really am but when
somebody just like picks up social media
there's so much out there like in my
head I was overthinking and saying well
they only have that one shot to see one
video to come back and learn who out you
know and get a chance to vibe with me
you know so when I'm in clinic I have
let me let me teach you the mentality I
have that this may be a huge break for
you for everybody's watching let me
teach you the difference between winning
88 to 13 versus losing one to zero
Olivia right now is thinking about
losing one to zero
Gary lives in thinking about winning 88
to 13 you think that one post can then
lead to one loss I think that one post
leads to eighty eight wins and 13 losses
and I don't give a [ __ ] about those 13
losses yeah got it and then when you
when you laugh at the end of your dance
you like oh [ __ ] I missed my elbow move
that's gonna make you endearing to a lot
of people and you're gonna have more
people like you and sign up with you
than the people like oh she's not
technically sound you're judging
yourself out of this ideology of
perfection that then leads to your
ambition because you're not
understanding the end consumer well
enough you're not understanding the
market well enough
the market is 88 to 13 when you're good
when you're bad it's 13 to 88 which is
why people don't grow actually when you
really suck at it
it's one two ninety nine nine hundred
people see it 99 take your corner you
suck and but like but even one 299 is a
better mentality and thinking using one
to zero the reason the up in made [ __ ]
six years is you're thinking about
losing one to zero and that's not how
content works yeah and I agree and it's
like I it was like so many things and
that's what I'm like I just kind of like
got out of what I knew I should be doing
and now I'm actually doing it so I'm
really going hard a that's good that's
good that's good that's cuz Kuroda is
gonna help a lot of people doing Coronas
gonna be devastating for tons of
families unfortunately around the world
it breaks my [ __ ] heart
but Corona don't get a twisted Corona is
gonna help so many people
this was the pause that you needed to
push this moment would have never
[ __ ] happen I need a meeting with
[ __ ] Jesus right now
you know like Coronas gonna help a lot
of people Olivia go take it go take it
please stop it Olivia if I don't see you
[ __ ] post five things today to tick
tocks to instagrams one YouTube like
stop [ __ ] make just talk tell a story
don't over now you're gonna be pumped
you're gonna hang up and but then 4hours
gonna be like what do I [ __ ] tell a
story
Telefunken story and I really yeah thank
you thank you alright I see people are I
see people are sharing thank you Mike
Vera Lottie JB user always good to see
you Adriana which good maryam mo but I I
see Twitter's quiet I need a lot more
tweets I need a lot more tweets take
some screenshots share it if you're
watching Twitter I need a lot more
tweets I'm Gary Vee on Twitter let's get
some sharing going and this time for
Denise hey Gary how are you I'm good and
yourself I'm well that's good to hear
well what I can say is I'm not quite
sure if you got a chance to read what I
reached
out to you with but um pretty much my
story is not like many people but a lot
of people when I say that it's like I
have so many ideas and I've always seen
you say that pretty much an ideas [ __ ]
there's no execution because it never
becomes real
exactly so there's your [ __ ] head
exactly so there's just so many ideas
that see I had to boil it down to brand
content like just grand content is just
something that I'm extremely passionate
about
I love taking something that's
absolutely nothing and making it huge
and I died and how have you experienced
that so far well I said when I was like
18 19 I started off managing the studio
okay and at first I didn't get the you
know the chance to you know really excel
until he finally was like you know what
I'm gonna give you the position and then
you know you can do as you please with
the studio and once he did that I was
able to get locals into the studio and
promote the studio and using what social
media Instagram or Facebook Twitter
especially Twitter Twitter was a hit for
me when it came to promoting the studio
by in in the form of the content or in
the form of community management
community management okay so everyone
would look how long what do you are you
a good writer I have to say yes I am are
you good at ideas really really good
ideas what are you just lack of Jersey
you want to work at vaynermedia sure
okay you kidding me right now I'm not
[ __ ] kidding you right now Wow you're
kidding I'm sorry I'm motional but this
is like unreal Denis I'm not kidding
like life is about giving people
opportunities you said yes to two things
we need whether it's team Gary or it's
on vaynermedia like we're hiring
creators and you're local what are you
Jerzy I live in Belleville love it I
think that you should apply for a job
and I have a funny feeling I know who to
talk to to help you okay
so you should email me right now at Gary
at vaynermedia and obviously right now
we're going through all this so I'm
having meetings ten hours a day to make
sure we're saving every job before we
start giving them out but okay says this
isn't gonna be too long for us and I
want you to meet the head of our
creative department I want you to meet
Andy on my team and we're gonna analyze
from our subjective opinion how good you
are I would send me an email with 50 to
10 to 50 posts that you posted for the
studio with links to the tweet the
Facebook and Instagram and then write a
line or two of why you did it
how you made it and when I say how you
made it did you come up with the idea
and write it did were you how did the
picture get me did somebody else do that
did you make that take that photo give
me how the piece was made and how you
thought about it 70 20 minimum 25 of
those and even if it's community
management like how you replied to this
person and why and and I have a funny
feeling your life just changed thanks
Gary you're welcome take care you're
welcome see ya bye [ __ ] giving out
jobs here during Corona on tea with Gary
Vee that's just how [ __ ] happens you
know I'd be lying if I didn't say Jersey
girls always have a soft spot in my
heart I just I just Eric what's good
hey Gary sorry to interrupt yo just
chatting with Dustin didn't mean he
couldn't keep don't worry bro I'm the
king of cutting people off so Oh Dustin
just me yeah no worries
so yeah just share share if you're
watching this right now look we're
[ __ ] giving people real advice I
think two of the piece of advice that
I've given are to the better piece of
advice I've ever given we just give
somebody a [ __ ] job like we need this
shared Dustin Wiggins I see you bro [ __ ]
you I'm telling everybody right now I
need every cent of 5,000 you [ __ ] BK
people [ __ ] watching this can the team
probably [ __ ] four five thousand
people ten thousand people watching this
right now and nobody's [ __ ] sharing it
on Twitter and I like looking at Twitter
while I'm doing this because I'm [ __ ]
a TV now and I need to see the action so
if you don't [ __ ] share the link to
this or your screenshot of this I'm
[ __ ] angry at you change your [ __ ]
lives let's [ __ ] go
Dustin what's good okay appreciate them
you know no super awesomeness you just
did I love I love the content you
produce I love the energy you give to us
entrepreneurs just deeply appreciate it
brother thank you thank you
Las Vegas is bright and early here right
now yes it is thank you my client my
question for you Gary is out of all the
experiences that you've had as an
entrepreneur considering your successes
and your failures yes what what is one
thing that you've learned that you wish
you understood when you just started out
that I that my biggest vulnerability was
that I I've al you positivity so much
that it's skewed too far and I was
unable to give critical feedback often
enough which led me to not being as can
Duras as its required to be a leader
which led to people for a good 20 years
of my career be surprised shocked or
appalled by being fired because I didn't
give a good enough feedback during the
process and that my kindness and
compassion was my strength but also Mike
was my macro strength but was a micro
vulnerability and needed to be rounded
out with candor and feedback and to this
day as I sit in front of you right now
it continues to be a weakness of mine
because I'm optimistic I put it all my
shoulders if Dustin Williams is not
performing I'm like okay I've got to
motivate him I'll figure out a different
thing I'll move his department I'll find
another way instead of saying like
Dustin you're just not putting in the
effort of the same people around you and
you're being exposed because this is
our decor place or Dustin like you're
insecure which is making you manage
people in a way that you know really
isn't like up to stuff here and I'm
really really concerned about it and so
you know that that is a that is a real
thing that I worry about that I need to
be more Candice that's cool can it can I
give you a chance to do that to me right
now
I can well what's funny is what's funny
is it's why I crush on Q&A it's cuz I'm
very can Duras when I do this because
you're an acquaintance or a friend when
somebody works for me than my family and
I and something broke down over 220
years there but I listen the reason I
can talk about it now is I've gotten to
a much better place much better place
real quick this is gonna be a learning
for everybody watch this I'm sorry
interrupts ustin whoever's woman on
Manning my Instagram live on my team
right now please bring in somebody into
like the queue like to FaceTime with
what team what that's gonna do is it's
gonna push back a push notification for
everybody that follows me and the 1200
people that are watching on Instagram
right now will bump up to 4 to 5,000 do
that every 10 minutes can you please
confirm on the whatsapp that whoever
uninsured am heard me on that and can do
that
the reap the Reeb UMP will help the Reeb
UMP will help anyway Justin go ahead
alright so for that candid feedback for
about a decade I've had a very deep
passion for bean entrepreneur and I've
been shooting everywhere like I've owned
a small dry cleaning business publishing
company I've done ecommerce private
labeling a little bit of manufacturing
just crazy all over the place and I love
everything I'm like so interesting
everything but oh and even even now I
own a about a year ago I invested in a
travel franchise which it's kind of a
rough time right now but I'm just all
over the place my social media content
loved your book crushing it is like my
youtube channel you can watch my kids
shave me
be giving a pitch on some business and
then you know some other crazy things
about a posh new language or something
so I'm just like all over the place and
I just feel like I I can never really be
truly successful at anything because I'm
just too busy doing everything by vocab
but I don't know if it's focused let's
dig here we'll go Candace have you ever
have you ever had a successful business
like and and and when you say yes or
kind of or tell me how successful that's
really what actually let me start over I
apologize what is the most successful
leave financial business you've ever had
during this run and it's okay brother
listen to me and listen to me good this
is real talk this is like we're turning
Corona into like so I tell me the truth
nothing but scrapping for me I haven't
gone into excessive amounts of debt
except for when I bought the dry
cleaning business
I'm gay Gary that was tough man like you
know you know how to small business you
know it's like 16 hours a day working
until my hands were bleeding like that
was insane but that was 2014 just got
back from Afghanistan I was in the
National Guard and couldn't find a job
when I got back I mean I did I was a
server for two dollars and 10 cents an
hour at some Utah restaurant and then a
911 dispatcher for like eight bucks an
hour so I was doing those two things I
was like I can't do this
so I bought a dry cleaning business knew
nothing about it I would say that went
into debt Oh significant amounts of debt
yeah I had a big house nice well his
business and it was just insane right my
student loans my wife student loans it
was wild and how were you I bought it
Rob how are you able to get what are you
able to borrow money because of your
status in the National Guard or because
people were just letting money in 2014
or why yeah I got I got a it was my um
my wife's father who owned several
businesses was able to lend
I understand yeah and I'm sure I heard
for a year in that business
I was non-stop living there and I bought
it wrong I didn't notice
I didn't know what to look for in a P&L
statement I didn't know why there was no
labor costs on there didn't even think
to look into ass but the dude had his
entire family in there working and I was
just by myself and profitable than it
was
labor costs in there because he had from
families understood so I had to hire
people all my profit that I was making
just went to fix fix put broken machines
hire people and it was just insane but I
did grow the business the revenue
increased about thirty five percent in
that first year why I started doing
implementing automations like listening
to advice from people like you the e
mist was a huge book for me that helped
me get through that but then like
because I wasn't paying for my family I
was going into excessive amounts of debt
on my credit card it was just insane and
then I got an offer from the government
to go serve as a teacher a full-time
military position how to take it sold
the business sold my house made it
enough money to pay off all of my debt
including my wife's loans my wife
student loans and my student loans all
the credit card debt the business
everything so I start I went from tons
of debt mountains of debt to zero I
didn't own anything but I didn't know
anything and that would be my most
successful I think how did you how did
you get the house just regular loan
conventional loan right so back in the
day you had some money you got alone and
in the house growing up during the
period of time that you bought it Oh big
time yes I made money off the house too
so how did you make money on the
cleaners where you use on the cleaners
but made money in the house and the
house covered everything yeah I think
the house pretty much covered everything
on that that's what I figured and that's
why I wanted to ask that question and
there's nothing wrong with that I think
so
first of all I really like you like
Annette let me let me let me be honest
here I think I think something I've been
thinking a lot about is likability and
and just a general vibe I've been
thinking a lot about this so I just
wanted to share that so what's your
question do I think you're an
entrepreneur or how should you how
should I think about like is a misnomer
people that blame lack of focus for why
they're not successful entrepreneurs are
trying to blame a micro thing for a
macro thing I'm the least [ __ ] focused
person I know and so and so are and so
are some of the most successful
entrepreneurs I know now
they she and him tend to be focused
enough on one core thing that affords
them to be lack of focus but I'm also
don't focus and I'm successful I've got
I'm a co-founder and incubated and on
the board of a company called resi and
resi goes and sells for nine figures -
Amex after five years I I'm trying to
I'm trying to build wine text and yummy
text if you drink wine or my food you
better sign up this wine techs and gummy
text for my dad that's what I'm doing
baseball card and sports card hustle
that I'm producing content that I'm
public speaking that I'm the CEO
thousand person company which is a
thousand person holding company so it
not only is vaynermedia but it's pure
Wow and 137 p.m. it's the Sasha group
it's been their speakers its tracer now
why can I do it because I'm tracer Jeff
Nichols center lady Welch I don't do
anything for that business like except
be there for them because they're
capable same with Zack that are invading
our speakers maybe I'm the biggest
speaker on there but Zack and Steve they
run that [ __ ] right Carol is senior you
know so like but I'm help their skelter
like crazy but I'm just great at being
an entrepreneur because I'm good at it
like it's what I'm good at you know and
like and like the reality is just
because you took a huge L on the
cleaning thing or a solid L that doesn't
scare me because you obviously didn't
grow up being a businessman and so you
and even if you did I would argue not
seeing that the P L didn't have
employees on it is a rookie mistake that
even people that were meant to go on and
build good businesses
growing the business 35% on the consumer
side is a big deal I would argue it's
harder to build a business 35% growth
than it is to learn the learnings of the
boring [ __ ] of P&L taxes things of that
nature so there's a lot of interesting
elements here yeah I grew up in a
trailer park in North Vegas very like I
did not have any growing up no no no
there's an unlimited amount of people
that grew up in trailer parks that went
on and built 100 million dollar
companies oh yeah okay it's not the
success but brother they had the natural
talent in the same way that you'd super
pretty eyes and that's what you were
given he's the same way that some people
were given entrepreneurship in the same
way that you were given the bravery to
defend this country like and I'm so
grateful for that and there's a lot of
people who support and honestly ye
Ernest I don't know you know I think if
I was drafted I would go but I don't
know if I have the DNA of like raising
my hand to go right I would say I would
always know if I got drafted I wouldn't
have been one of those people in the 70s
that went to Canada or faked of the
injury I would have [ __ ] gone but I
wouldn't have been [ __ ] raised my
hand and gone yet
like that's not in my stomach but it's
one of the reasons I even signed up for
the military was I read an article in
Forbes they talked about these leaders
in these fortune 500 companies for
veterans prior military service I was
like all right there must be something
there that I I I'm worried that the kid
that grows up in a trailer park puts
money on a pedestal and puts business on
a pedestal because they didn't have it
yeah you're probably right I know I mean
the amount of people that don't come
from money that then put money on a
pedestal versus for example not coming
for money but it was my call I didn't
know anything else brother at five years
old six years old I didn't there was
nothing I didn't know what business
existed when I was pulling flowers out
of yards and selling it I didn't know
business I didn't know I mean this at
six years old as an immigrant in a
Russian tell me I don't know that
business I don't I mean no that business
existed when I started a lemonade stand
I didn't know I'm not even sure I
understood business existed when I was
doing baseball cards it was my calling I
was like I always think a business for
me like you know those
things that those zapping light things
that sit outside in people's porches
yeah absolutely
what are they called like zapper
whatever the [ __ ] they are those lights
that to me is business and I'm like a
little [ __ ] ladybug or a fly or a
wasp just flying right into it there was
no other option it wasn't because it was
a reaction to my financial status I
wasn't sitting in a trailer park at
11:00 saying let me get out of here it's
money money I'm never gonna I'm never
gonna [ __ ] worry about next paycheck
or worry of running out of gas a lot of
people put money on a pedestal out of
dire situations which gives them a bad
relationship with the game of
entrepreneurship because they're trying
to use the game to give them money
they're not respecting and loving the
game for the [ __ ] eight you're right
you're totally right and I had this
realization recently cuz I've gone
through dozens of failures and I think
my main I think this is why I failed to
be honest with you because I put money
as the focus not serving others brother
serving yourself like I love my [ __ ]
game like I loved it right now I love
that I'm gonna hang up in an hour in
seven minutes and go into a finance call
and try to figure out some sort of thing
with snacks or the security guards at
Long Island City or travel expenses
because I have to save every job to the
best of my ability and then I'm gonna
have to go into next week or the week
after and have the really tough process
of going through every employee and
realizing that we've had we had seven to
ten employees that were on the being let
go block a week before Corona and some
of them like we just didn't get around
to it was gonna be the next week and you
know and like what do I do with them
right like like those are people that
are underperforming that are detrimental
to our business but right now even
though the right count the council on
getting which is proper from my
leadership which is like look we're
gonna have to still make those needs it
is this is the new normal I'm struggling
with doing that during this time but at
the same token then that makes people
that are crushing it vulnerable if this
is prolonged that's [ __ ] you know what
a rock and a hard place is that's insane
yeah but guess what I love it that's my
richest exciting yeah
it's it's exciting not because I'm in
control it's exciting because I I don't
know anything other than being
accountable being a leader put it on my
back I got this guys I got this girls
like that's who I am in business I'm not
sure that I'm that guy when it's going
into enemy territory in Afghanistan I
don't know if I'm that guy I don't think
I'm the I got this guy I got these girls
like I don't think I'm back I don't
think I'm I got this guys I got this
gals when the shed breaks during a
tornado and we have to rebuild it I
don't want to [ __ ] build a shed and
you know in the backyard like like you
know like I don't you know you know I
don't know you know
there's a lot of things that I'm not but
I am an entrepreneur and during this
period right now we're about to find out
who is and isn't and and I can promise
you right now in one man's point of view
an entrepreneur is not going to be the
entrepreneur that I define when she or
he does it strictly for the money and a
lot of people do it for the money and a
lot of them do it because didn't grow up
with it a lot of them do it because
they're insecure they did grow up with
it they needed to continue their [ __ ]
reputation I do it a [ __ ] game and
you need to figure out what you like and
I would argue that it's servicing me let
alone servicing people I don't think
it's the way your sentence was described
was very altruistic then very noble but
I don't believe in that I believe that
[ __ ] entrepreneurship is serving me it
is my oxygen it's the blood that runs
through me I am built for it and and I
feel like right now entrepreneurships on
such a pedestal that a lot of people who
are numbers Justin I promise you right
now just have been spending a little
time with you you'd be a really good
number seven with me you'd be a really
good number seven with me you know what
I mean and right now a lot of people who
are number Seven's want to be number
ones cuz it's cool or they want the
[ __ ] money and they're gonna get
caught and I think you've continued to
get caught and I think you need to have
that conversation with yourself
or find something that you love so much
and then build a business model on top
of it
have you read crush it oh absolutely
absolutely I love that book go read it
right now go we go okay because what I
wrote in 2008 I haven't implemented a
lot of it like I'm not posting daily
because I'm all over the place and I
don't feel like I don't know that's not
true being a little bit of places the
this back to UM for everybody out there
right now who's blaming I'm all over the
place had too many interest there's too
many ideas of all of you're [ __ ] full
of [ __ ] that means you more [ __ ] to post
about great yeah Justin you're not in a
creators mindset you're not taking a
screenshot of this right now and then
posting it on on Instagram you're gonna
do it now watching your eyes you're not
in a creator mindset you're not in the
mindset of a creator that I try to get
crush it into which is right now you
take a screenshot of this and this
becomes a great Instagram post where you
let your whole heart out and you write a
[ __ ] manifesto underneath this picture
and say look Gary Vee [ __ ] gave me a
you know how some people get a back
readjustment Gary just give me an
entrepreneurial mental adjustment I've
got to take a step back right in your
[ __ ] heart out that's gonna your most
successful Facebook post and by the way
when you're in a place when you're all
over the place you're golfing you're
picking up coffee you're talking to your
wife
you're [ __ ] bit like this you walk by
cleaners and take a photo you can create
content all day long crush it is not
about posting all day long though that
is part of it
crushing is about hey if you love steel
hey if you love tea hey if you love the
Yankees you have to start making content
around that and then you can lay your
business on top you love the Yankees
like everybody who's home right now
[ __ ] stuck start a podcast so you do
show in Instagram around your favorite
thing make videos about if you love an
NFL team you're set there's free agency
there's things to talk about become your
local sportscaster take your hot cakes
post and then
a year of that maybe get to a place
where somebody wants to sponsor your
Yankees podcast the yankee shop for
twenty five hundred a month and you
start building you start building it's
about building a business around
something that makes you happy not the
business that you think is gonna make
you the most money do you know why
everybody's integrating cryptocurrency
and cannabis and social media and real
estate and and and Wall Street's with
money money and and when you make money
the goal you become [ __ ] vulnerable
mentally you become vulnerable [ __ ]
mentally I know [ __ ] unlimited people
that [ __ ] went into something
actually made the money but they [ __ ]
hate it and three years at first they
needed the money but three years in now
they've got the money and now it's
[ __ ] handcuffs
cuz they need the money because now they
started spending and people who don't
have anything when they get money then
they start buying dumb [ __ ]
that's part of the whole equation of the
psychology of not coming or anything and
getting money they want the money not
for stability and peace of mind they
want the money for the BMW that they saw
the rich people don't when they walked
across the highway from the trailer park
to go to the ball and like one day I'm
gonna have one of those they put [ __ ]
things on a pedestal their insecurities
of their status is driving them and that
and plenty of people can be successful
from deep insecurity but they're not
happy [ __ ] people let there be no
[ __ ] confusion on this team with Gary
Vee I'm not talking about successful
entrepreneurship I'm talking successful
life absolutely yep I agree yes 100%
Gary and your beast Gary thank you for
the daily grind and awesome content you
put out really wide [ __ ] rewatch this I
will have this conversation with you if
you if you're gonna start if you're
gonna start another business build it
around the thing that is your number one
hobby or your number one curiosity or
your number one interest it--on below
about yeah I talk a lot about Yankees
I would also talk about like if you wish
you were let's talk about something else
I'd never talk about you just thought of
it or the journey I think an incredible
podcast youtube series and Instagram
content and tick tock for you would be
the journey of becoming a chef
with Dustin Wiggins hey everybody I'm
gonna roleplay I'm using the corona to
really go deeper ready I'm gonna
roleplay
let's make pretend you wanted to
Michelle this is for everybody not
necessarily maybe you and then maybe
I'll ask you what your favorite thing is
everybody it's Dustin Wiggins I'm
starting this new show big shout out to
Gary Vee for finally pushing me to do
this certainly show with called the
journey of becoming a chef with me
Dustin Wiggins in this show in all my
content on social you'll be seen me
trying to become a chef after this rare
encounter chance encounter with Gary Vee
on livestream a couple weeks ago he
encouraged me and I realized I vote I
really want to be a cook now let me
start by saying this the reason it's
called the journey becoming a chef is I
might not succeed I might not be great
at cooking but what you're gonna see in
today's episode first I'm gonna tell you
little about me about you know what you
know how I grew up in a trailer park how
I went to Afghanistan how I failed in a
laundry mat where I am in my life but
what this show is really gonna be about
is like literally you the world and I
know right now there's only four of you
watching thanks for my family and like
my father-in-law and like my two friends
but like but soon and hopefully this
will be bigger this is gonna be the
journey of me becoming a chef you're
gonna literally watch me watch youtube
videos and learn how to slice with a
sharp knife and I'm sure I'm gonna cut
my finger and leave you're gonna watch
as I taste things I've never tasted
before like what the [ __ ] is foie gras
and escargot this is going to be me
trying to become a chef I hope you enjoy
it
each week I'll answer a couple of
questions about you going through what
journey you're going through I have a
tip of the day once a week I'm gonna try
to put out a recipe I'm sure they're
gonna suck at first but this is gonna be
one of the great journeys now let me
transition to Who I am I was born in a
trailer park that that Dustin that is
for you and everybody else who either
there's two ways to go about this there
is no excuse for anybody tonight I'm
starting a podcast country show and a
Content series on the tic-tock and
Instagram and Twitter and Facebook
here's why either you love the Yankees
so much and you start your Yankee show
let me give you the new one
listen excellent hey everybody it's Mike
playa stuck yet the Corona thing my
business isn't working right now
starting this podcast about you know
Yankee talk with my client
group a Yankees fan in Long Island all
right now I'm really worried and let's
some better rotation really worried
about J either that you're that guy or
girl because you love the Yankees or
you've always wanted to learn how to you
and you start a format called the
journey of becoming that person and now
you're documenting you're either a fan
and have expertise Miyagi's cuz you love
it or you're documenting
the journey of becoming something you
wish you were and and those two formats
cover every [ __ ] that's watching this
episode of tea with Gary B I want no
[ __ ] excuses I'm not worrying about
what people [ __ ] worry about let's
create content appreciate you really see
you I don't know what everybody thinks
but like if you don't tweet that this is
the most brilliant [ __ ] content
I mean I'm giving it my all like I've
been winning in content for a decade
like I'm taking it to the next step on
this tea with Gary Vee like well [ __ ]
changing lives out here
join the [ __ ] coronavirus who's next
nice guy hey Gary I miss can hear me hi
good morning good morning oh my gosh I'm
so excited I'm about to cry so I'm not
gonna cry yeah I hope my kids are
watching this because my son's about to
fan and he turned me on to you and I
just this is such a hard time right now
yes
educators especially it's just great
it's crazy it's absolutely crazy and I
just I just appreciate you so much for
what you're doing for everyone but
especially me today I'm just very
excited yeah what can I answer for you
um I you know I am an educator I've been
an educator for 23 years
um teaching is what I know although I
have tons of other interests I've owned
businesses with my husband I've always
had a side gig I was listening to you
talk about when you started as a child I
you know I came from an entrepreneurial
fan
I started cleaning houses when I was 10
I was babysitting I was you know making
money and hustling as a child and now as
a teacher like my everyday reality has
been taken from me um my sense of
structure my sense of routine I'm used
to you know every 15 20 minutes I have a
routine I have something to do every 15
20 minutes and so being home my
husband's working from home I'm driving
him absolutely insane at ease you know
an IT guy he's on this computer and he's
like what are you doing sit down and I
just I'm just really struggling and I
know I hear my educators I hear their
voices I hear my colleagues I'm getting
text messages all day long about like oh
my god what do I do I don't know how to
do this online platform I don't know
what to do about my students I don't
know how to use oome I don't understand
distance learning and you know the
districts are doing the best they can
and I'm also a union rep I represent my
colleagues at the state level I
represent my colleagues at the local
level and there's so much going on that
we have to make sure we're minding our
P's and Q's right we have to be very
careful as educators what we put out on
content everything's being looked at the
district can pull all of our stuff and
and I feel like everyone's just in panic
mode you know they're just completely
panicking and I know I'm born to be a
leader I know that I know I'm stuck it's
my time to step up and lead I like I
know that in my heart and I'm just I
don't know how well you don't know how
no I'll tell you why you don't know how
I believe that you're a leader I could
even tell by the way you're talking and
then you tell me about the union rep and
all that I actually think the biggest
thing you're struggling with is you
agree with them that things are bad and
scary you're struggling right now it's
just so obvious is it for example if you
were like me
the reason I'm kind of cruising and I
mean cruising through this period right
now as a leader is cuz I actually don't
think it's so horrible I think you and I
actually I think the biggest thing this
guy can help you with is like actually
having this conversation with you of
like let's put this thing into
perspective
I need that okay so let's do that first
and foremost and and this may be and you
me say you know this will this will be
my authentic relief and it might be a
different than your belief but I think
it would be good to put things into
perspective perspective number one
I feel zero anxiety if every child in
America completely and utterly got no
education from today until September
first
that was me yeah I I agree I don't I
feel like right now okay good let's see
there let's actually stay there let's
actually actually I'm very excited I'm
so excited when it's what's about to
happen because you saying that and me
believing you I'm trying to make my own
judgments has me so excited because we
basically I'm just giving you the
preview we've already won yeah let me
explain why if the reason you can't
leave your fellow teachers right now is
because you in you know you're getting
bombarded with constant negativity
whether it's on TV whether it's in
social media whether it's through your
text right you're you're taking on their
anxiety that they don't know how to use
right yes yes you know you're you're a
compassionate person which is why you're
probably a leader and so you're taking
on Sally like you love Sally and you
feel bad for her because you know she's
sad and her uncle's no [ __ ] idea how
to use right so you're taking us all on
yeah but that's because you're looking
in the micro not the macro let me
explain okay
if in your mind you said why are we even
teachers let's go up a notch if we are
here to educate these incredibly
wonderful youthful kids and you agree
with me that if they get zero structural
education from a school system whether
clearly now virtually for the next 90
days but this will not be the great
catastrophe of our time a hundred
percent I agree 100 percent so stick
with me here now if you actually believe
that when Carol text you like I don't
[ __ ] understand zoo and parents are
gonna be minute and then when you call
her and say Carol actually I
Carroll let's call a spade a spade I
mean these [ __ ] kids these kids
aren't gonna be paying attention anyway
they're gonna have another screen open
and happy parents aren't gonna make them
do it anyway and let's be honest you
know I know it's [ __ ] fifth grade and
they're taking the National quarter but
like but like let's call it [ __ ]
spade a spade they're gonna every child
in America in the world right now is
gonna learn more through the serendipity
of going through adversity who they are
I'm sure a lot of them to spend time
with family that they would have
normally not stories looking through old
pictures they're gonna learn about
themselves a lot of them are gonna love
do you know many kids are gonna go back
to school in September with a renewed
love and appreciation for school because
it seemed great on paper but then they
realize the social aspect and the
routine Miska yeah this is a piece of
cake Miska you are your
great-grandmother went to the [ __ ]
wars like years yes
wars wars the [ __ ] are we really crying
about eight days at home like who gives
a [ __ ] your [ __ ] mister rippers
doesn't know how to use [ __ ] zoo I
don't have the right perspective right
now I know I'm taking on all of their
anxiety and I feel nervous to speak my
mind you agree with them and yeah
actually I'm sorry hey I believe I
believed that you agree with them if
it's be that you're scared to speak your
mind well well speak your mind to me
what's your mom like honest no [ __ ]
what is your mind that you're scared to
speak up on when you when you are having
these interactions I think I could care
less 100% if they're doing any online
learning actually I teach five-year-olds
and I want them to feel safe I want them
to connect with their families I want
them to get outside and breathe some
fresh air I want them to know that I
care I zoomed with my kids the other day
had five kids on they were so excited
they showed me their toys and they were
bringing everything out they were
showing me their dogs and they were
excited to see their friends it's about
connection or relationship it has zero
percent to do about let's get them on it
on
learning lesson I mean the district is
trying to invest might understand that
they're pushing out a packet like what
the [ __ ] is a packet gonna do for a
five-year-old what's a packet gonna do
for a child they're they're gonna be 12
when they leave us and they they don't
need they don't need what the district
is pushing out I understand I sent a
text to my colleagues yesterday I said I
don't you know I care zero percent about
the online learning I care about their
hearts I care about their mentality I
care about their anxiety levels I care
about are they safe I care about do they
know that we we care about them i 100%
care about the relationships and the
connection and teachers are freaked out
right now and I care about them I care
deeply about them because I understand
where they're coming from so I did I've
been putting a lot out there about like
managing my own anxiety I've been
watching a lot of you know Brenda
Rashard I'm taking a good wellness class
online I've been really just learning
myself up instead of consuming like I
don't watch the news because it gives me
anxiety anyway like I need to see
something I follow the who I follow CDC
that's what I follow and and I'm let's
go one day one thing one thing that I
think you and everybody else is
listening should also take advantage of
during this time I would argue that I
want you to watch more CNN or Fox more
Facebook more Twitter because it's not
about people think the way to solve
things is cutting it out I think the way
to solve things is to calibrate it
there's a fundamental difference between
cutting out and calibrating yeah if
you're gonna run oh you know people are
running away from it because it gives it
like work on yourself to quantify the
information right like what you're like
to me back to school terms one of the
things that happened to me in school was
I learned how to quantify the
information that I decided was gonna
bring me value in my self-esteem and
self awareness that I had even at a very
young age which was a blessing and a
gift and great parenting and serendipity
but like that's why I paid attention to
history class because I thought that
patterns and human patterns would be
valuable that's why I can talk to you
about your great grandmother I I'm
struggling
outside a family that has a death
because of Corona yeah is the ultimate
because that is war outside of that
everybody else I'm struggling with
because I'm trying to get them to create
perspective around what their
great-grandmother's went through yeah my
family came from Hungary so I get it my
dad came when he was you know twelve
years old and you know things but you
really do it up I get it I get it I'm
from an immigrant family and but
generations I get that but but I need
you to really get it because your
anxiety right now it doesn't get it
you're full of [ __ ] now and if your
house is about [ __ ] Corona for a week
in the house safest stop with the
[ __ ] Internet and with zoom and
[ __ ] all these blessings you don't
[ __ ] get it right get it you get it
on paper I need you to put in your
[ __ ] soul yeah I and I need to I just
need to I need to it like you said
before so every other person execute
execute and share and tell stories and
miss Scott you know deal huh yeah your
[ __ ] father was 12 a 12 year old
child we live in an America now where
parents don't let 12 year olds go
outside by themselves cuz they're scared
of you and everything your father less
hungry and came to America there's 42
year olds I don't know how to do that
like do you think like do you understand
the lat you understand that your
great-great-great-great grandmother and
grandfather in heaven right now from
hungry or everything from looking down
at you and make fun of you yeah like
like not getting groceries I didn't want
a [ __ ] joke like I I don't I like I'm
not and I'm not rising on you this is
macro talk I don't have my routine yes
yet that's life this yeah a great
opportunity for you to get used to not
having a [ __ ] routine that's what
life's about that's what that's what
pandemic is about that is what an
economic down
turn is about that is what everybody has
gone through we are human beings Black
Plague World War two the [ __ ]
Holocaust talking about here we're
babies yeah you know you know you're a
woman you like sexism that's been your
entire life they're like you know
minorities in this country relationships
with authorities of like misnomer is
like what do we your routine you're
right you don't get it like me going to
the gym and getting my coffee in the
morning that's the way like I have to
start my day and your seven dollar
coffee it is like how you live as a
human suck your [ __ ] leader be a
[ __ ] leader speaking truth and
[ __ ] build real perspective there's
not a there's not a single average in
America is better off what they're gonna
learn right now than what the normal
curriculum would have been in their
[ __ ] classroom the last three [ __ ]
months this is a blessing every teacher
should rejoice and all the things that
kids are gonna learn about I'm gonna
learn about themselves
yeah and see how the [ __ ] robot
[ __ ] curriculum like [ __ ] routine
that they were used to not giving up
yeah but texting when you guys turned
around and wrote on the board I know you
had five year olds but I'm just for all
teachers like take a step back goodness
they're gonna have the rest of the
[ __ ] light in the normal way of
school this three-year there's three
months things a [ __ ] Mitzvah let me
know [ __ ] learn something yeah I get
it
so can I ask you another question so I'm
gonna side hustle on the side has some
good I've just been kind of sitting on
it it's network marketing and I'm a
little nervous to pull the trigger and I
don't know why it's probably I know why
it's because I'm afraid of what people
are going to think if I reach out so
what's your advice there
health and wellness and look I don't
know I'm I personally and a lot of
people get mad at me when I say this but
I'm comfortable just like you told you
I'm not a humongous fan of the structure
of what network marketing looks like
like how its structured with the trees
and the theatres and I have plenty of
wonderful people who come say you're a
dick Gary and you're wrong
so a a you know to me you have to ask
yourself why you're scared to reach out
are you scared to reach out because
you're not a natural salesperson and
even if you're selling this mug on the
internet or door-to-door you'd feel
uncomfortable or like many people that I
talk to are you fearful because you
actually deep down you may know a friend
or two that have been financially
successful with network marketing but
you and your soul don't actually like me
don't actually believe in the way it's
structured and how people are
compensated and selling on selling and
selling on people it's not even about
the product is about the structure and
the system and they're kicking back you
ask yourself that question okay all
right love you thank you all right I
think so much this guy
listen to me be a [ __ ] leader I am
thank you so much you got it let's keep
this going but I guess what do you think
some good [ __ ] huh yeah definitely
Savage it's good
name a little too much like Randy the
Macho Man Savage and trying to jump in
the ring before it was my turn so I
apologize for cutting you off you didn't
cut me off go ahead so Gary my question
is I'm 28 years old I've been working on
my side hustle for about the last six
and a half years and last June I
actually jumped ship from my big
corporate job and launched a full-time
digital agency focused on content
creation and social media management
they get in something I worked for six
years
every time I'm trying to you try to put
vaynermedia out of business bro I'm not
absolutely I'm trying to learn from
their media you've done some really
great things but I want you to win I'm
kidding good so Mike my question really
is around obviously the obvious happened
you know Corona happened lost all of my
clients but one thankful for that one
doing absolutely everything I can to
maintain that one to keep the doors open
luckily it's just me right now I've
always leveraged just part-time people
to kind of fill the gaps or the voids
whatever the scope you know goes beyond
what you know I can come to be deliver
so my question is around soliciting new
business from a be very distractive yes
like is it tone-deaf to be doing that
obviously you know plenty are gonna be
distracted it's yep it's tough it's
tone-deaf to be in sales it's brilliant
to be in branding do you want me to
explain Eric yes please
I think it's potentially tone-deaf to be
like even no matter how much you
disguise it like hey like ya get a free
week of my service dandy stuff like I
think some people will be turned off you
making unlimited LinkedIn videos about
what-if scenarios right if you started
what if with Eric Savage on LinkedIn and
said what if I was a dry cleaners during
this time here's what I would do with
social media brother I always say watch
what I do not what I say
I've started a two-hour cue a morning
tea show because I'm making content cuz
branding and content is always right
because you're not asking for the sale
you're creating demand
nobody from Nike calls you and says
would you like to buy a pair of sneakers
right they build a brand and then you
want to buy sneakers nobody from Burger
King call
like hey would you like a Big Mac no no
they build a brand and then you come too
many people think they're marketing and
branding people but what they are sales
people and when they get desperate they
become real sales people there's nothing
wrong with sales I love sales during a
time like this to your point and good
kudos on you of worrying about tone
death this is the time for you to create
fake scenarios and so I would start what
ifs around scenarios of kind of SMEs and
businesses that you'd like to hire you
yeah that's an amazing advice and then
my other question was depending on how
long this kind of street goes with
Corona which again hopefully it it can
be solved soon but as a new small
business owner how that's going through
it you know big a crisis for the first
time what aren't these things that I can
learn from this but also how can I avoid
from this I don't say scarring me but
being overly sensitive now to cash flow
or being overly too conservative or I
need to be going on the offense so do
you have any tips about you know going
through crisis before in your life of
owning the business of what do I hold on
to but yet what do I try to block out
going forward
cash is oxygen right being practical but
cash comes in a lot of form there's a
lot of people I know that Gary like I
need the government's help I'm like no
you don't you have $7,000 with a junk in
your [ __ ] house sell it on eBay right
like every like like like so cash comes
in a lot of ones its cash in the bank it
stocks that are worth half or you know
20 30 40 50 percent less it but it also
comes in the form of [ __ ] in your house
like that orange hat is seven dollars on
[ __ ] Facebook marketplace you know so
cash is important that's number one but
then also having humility to be basic
the humility to be simplistic the
humility to be minimized you know this
is so cash moving out of your house
moving out of your apartment to a lower
apartment because you can save four
hundred thirteen dollars right you know
just really analyze you know every
single person watching right now that's
scared and crying and feels like the
government should fix them should look
at their credit card bill and realize
they're paying for eight things on
subscription that they don't need right
so cash is oxygen and then number two I
play worst-case scenario I'm a big WCC
right worst-case scenario you know for
you not to be scarred or demonized so
you picked the wrong time to start the
business the [ __ ] Corona came in 52
years you're gonna tell the story about
how funny that was and the worst-case
scenario is you lose this one client and
in parallel of trying to get another
client and get a job when it might be
hard to get a job you're just gonna
grind and you're gonna learn how to be
humble as [ __ ] if I were you do you have
any say you have any money shape I do a
little bit so we're good for the next
couple of months but not all so cute as
a human right correct as a human and
what are your expenses as a human rent
student loans a car payment but again
I've probably got maybe three months
left that you know I'm good to go before
I just bleed out do you have stuff yeah
yeah of course I think you should sell
stuff and I mean this Eric this advice
is for you and everybody else I think
this I think that we should start
actually hey up being team Gary I want
to start sell stuff Saturday let's work
on that for this upcoming Saturday if
your team if you're watching let's start
working on logos let's start working up
with a strategy and here's what it is I
think this Saturday we should create
sell stuff Saturday you know Facebook
marketplace a little tough because
people pick up from each other right now
with Corona but eBay is still quite
active I've been watching it Eric I
think you should be the poster child for
sell stuff Saturday when I hear three
months and you know this most people
don't go into let me audit every single
thing in my [ __ ] apartment right now
everything I mean Eric let's play a
little bit they and some of these things
may work and they may not but let's
start with clothes right what percentage
of the clothes that you have in your
closet right now do you actually wear
I'll be perfectly honest probably 20%
great so when I think about 80% of your
clothes being something you could sell
on eBay now one of the things I really
like it for you is you also need to
learn sales brand and marketing and
market demands you selling on eBay is
actually going to also help you with
your agency a year from now so for you
you know selling stuff Saturday is gonna
be a huge deal because not only are you
gonna put another month in the kabhi and
by the way
Veronica Lee I think this thing sits in
the two three four month range anyway so
like could you imagine the serendipity
of this zoom this tea time Gary B leads
to you selling a bunch of [ __ ] you mean
anyway learning how to be a marketer a
copywriter a supply and demand er a
researcher what the right price is do I
do buy it now do I starting option
learning right and that gives you the
extra month which was the one extra
month you actually needed and you're a
more skill I mean this is like a [ __ ]
cool yeah yeah what else what else what
else you got that something what value
will that's luck it's it in the house
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] an Xbox a
[ __ ] bicycle what he got what other
stuff give me your top three stuffed
things
everybody's watching right now please
tweet out with hashtag sell stuff
Saturday with the three items that are
the most valuable that you least give a
[ __ ] about that you gonna sell this
Saturday on ebay Macari Craig's Leggett
I think it's a shipping thing because
the corona thing but like Eric for you
let's play here like what are the three
like what are the three most valuable
things you have right now in your
apartment that you're actually in take a
photo of list itself absolutely my
number one sell stuffing and it's
actually I don't know if it's a good
sign or bad so I can go right to these
three things but it's number one it's a
a triathlon bicycle it's like super
high-end flip that's a couple grand
right there hopefully quick without
knowing your expenses if you let's say
you sell let's say the markets down a
little bit people take advantage it
sells less you say a couple grand let's
just say it's 950 bucks even though
that's a low number but let's say you
get because you might have to put that
one on Craigslist yeah cuz it's hard to
ship that but you know there's gonna be
people that are gonna be willing to come
and pick it up I mean I'm sure you could
actually put it outside of your
apartment watch it from the door
hopefully nobody steals and somebody
comes and picks it up so there's social
distancing with Facebook and Craigslist
now that I think about it something will
be too scared and really creepy added
you know I get that but some will still
buy so let's say because of all those
dynamics you at nine fifteen cents well
50 how much more time what is your
monthly expenses in your mind when you
say you have three months how much is it
per month it's around 1,800 bucks cool
the fact that fifty percent like think
about this you're sitting here for the
last three four days saying fat guy
three months [ __ ]
right yes Miguel you want a [ __ ] bike
because you have this great ideology
that you're gonna be a [ __ ] triathlon
[ __ ] and meanwhile you [ __ ] wrote
it three times and suck it's sitting in
your house like isn't this cool though
isn't perspective cool like another half
month is sitting in your pocket maybe
even a full month back to you saying a
couple grand maybe I'm wrong about it
but isn't that cool
yes yeah it definitely optimism and
that's it's it's offense versus defense
I want the government to help me I'm in
big trouble
I'm scared meanwhile I'm like a
triathlon Bucky and my bike in my
[ __ ] house the guys me another
[ __ ] month oh yeah number two yeah
for me it's it's definitely an old
laptop I recently upgraded laptops this
year you know it's an Apple computer so
that's a couple hundred bucks probably
what's that can go next and then number
three it's gonna go you know you can
tell if the orange beanie I'm trying to
be trendy it's you know all sorts of
street wear jackets you know cool
sneakers things like that at the end the
day you can always rely on the other
side of you know Corona or whatever so
that's probably couple hundred bucks and
that's old anything have you ever sold
anything on the internet I you know I'm
and I'm not lying to you I actually did
I just recently moved to Nashville about
two months ago to be around musicians
because I work log musicians and I
literally paid for my entire movie
expenses by selling a ton of old
sneakers and things in my closet on ebay
only I mean a couple hundred thousand is
easy stock ex posting on your Instagram
where you just say who wants this for
five hundred bucks doing somebody should
be really innovative and do like a QVC
livestream on Facebook walking around
their house and saying how much email me
like if you're like that kind of
character you know Macari you know offer
up close there's some other like posts
Poshmark ebay craigslist facebook
marketplace Eric I'm really excited man
like I really think you just bought
yourself minimally another month
probably another two but do me a favor
take this energy and literally like
clothes laughs and like literally go
post now no I absolutely will cuz I I
appreciate you saying this like said
obviously I've sold before but sometimes
in you know we started
fearful in your head you things kind of
events yeah this is giving you you know
kind of an agenda to view the rest today
it's jump off for call and start posting
listings I mean it's sad actually
let's make selling stuff Saturday a
global phenomenon if somebody major
right now with big audiences if you can
share this let's make this a global
phenomenon this is gonna help so many
people are a good luck brother
thanks Gary appreciate your time you got
it that was a good idea let's see how
many people are tweeting so it's tough
said there we go boom there we go Stacy
Howard I'm retweeting you Steve amazing
there we go
who else is gonna selling stuff Saturday
James slice if you guys want followers
on Twitter this your chance because I'm
retweeting the [ __ ] out of all of you
everybody so far not that many people
had use the hash tag so it's tough
Saturday but Steve amazing what you've
said all sets of baseball cards classic
finals memorabilia let's [ __ ] go
let's keep this going Johnny K alright
so I'm a junior at high school and I own
a lawn mowing business in my town and my
last year I had 16 to 20 clients and
this offseason I've kind of invested in
a riding lawnmower a trailer I have a
truck already and I just want to know
what I can do to help build that and get
more clients and stuff I would run
Facebook active money couple months good
have you ever run a Facebook ad to try
to get custody I did last year yeah how
many different pictures and videos did
you run in your local area like when you
when you ran the ad in your town right
yeah just I'm like we like a Facebook
town page so I granted on that and stuff
like that but oh so that means that
means you paid a group to like post
something not really okay did you run
actual Facebook ads what town do you
live in Washington Illinois got it so
did you go into the ad the ads admin and
put you know 25 to 60 year olds in
Washington Illinois and then make an ad
that runs in people's feeds or you post
it on a community board I just posted on
a community board the number one thing I
want you to do Johnny K is to learn how
to run Facebook Ads okay when you learn
that and so
how do you do that you literally whoo
whoo laughter we're done here how to run
Facebook ads and you watch 10 YouTube
videos
you're young kid it comes easier to you
I want you to run your first Facebook ad
today even though it's a terrible time
to run an ad for a lot more you know but
I want you to just learn spend a hundred
bucks to learn on here's the key with
ads Johnny you're gonna the ads are two
things who do you target like what's the
planning strategy and then what content
do you put in front of them for you it's
easy you're just gonna go after 30 to 70
year olds in your town and the five
surrounding counties or wherever you're
willing to go do this right yeah your
key is going to be the [ __ ] content
that you put in the ad I think a funny
thing to do is actually have you film
yourself or some of your family right
now film you literally on the lawnmower
right now and be like I know it's Corona
season but just so you know I'm sitting
my house and I can't wait to this
[ __ ] summer - I'm say [ __ ] - this
summer to mow your lawn I think
customers now you know if you said hey
look me now and get a 10% discount for
this summer uh you might get some
customers now you need to learn how to
do Facebook ads it will triple your
business okay nice and Johnny take care
yeah thank you so much you're looking
better let's get going
I need more tweets everybody like what a
lot of you not have Twitter's like 7000
of you watching I'm get like a tweets
come on let's step it up I need to know
what you're selling on selling stuff
Saturday let's go John
area how you doing I'm real quick I
apologize look like I'm looking at some
of the stuff that people are listing and
I don't think it's gonna sell very well
but that's okay like what what I'm most
excited about is for a lot of you
learning how to come up with titles for
eBay posts pictures for emails for
facebook pictures for craigslist
pictures from acharya Poshmark
like just the learning of supply and
demand the learning of selling something
on the internet is more valuable than
even if you sell and the dollars and
during this time when everyone's you
know driven crazy what I'm gonna do with
myself this is gonna be a huge
huge thing sell it stuff Saturday let's
make it big if you're watching right now
hashtag selling stuff Saturday on
Twitter right now with the things you to
be selling I'm retweeting a bunch of you
so a bunch of you are gonna get all
sorts of new [ __ ] followers on
Twitter is your chance to grow so hacked
me let's make this a movement John
Thomas what's good hey what's going on
so I run tap cancer out a non-profit if
anyone was watching if you're into
grappling or MMA I hope you check it out
but obviously John what we have a
problem was that there is a Patriots
helmet over your right shoulder there's
also a David Ortiz bobblehead - Big Papi
doesn't bother me the logo and we'll go
right back to I promise that's harsh
that's hard wait I know in the harsh man
but I'm a simple boy thank you sir I
appreciate that
I took it around I really push it I
appreciate so much like an IQ - good job
so uh so yes it's a it's a sort of an
awkward time for nonprofits not just men
but for all we're a vent base we're
actually supposed to have our biggest
one this weekend so it's also a scary
time - sorry I was not planning to not
have all that revenue so we have events
towards the end of the year that I'm you
know I'm fairly confident we'll host and
that should be fine having the chat we
talked about we talked before yeah I was
in for DS I remember this I remember
your whole bit I don't yeah keep going
brother
I loved your model by the way I really
appreciate what you do why don't you
give everybody actually let's give a big
shout out to it why don't you take one
minute real quick go fast 30 seconds on
what you guys do yeah so so we host
charitable Brazilian Jujitsu tournaments
so we have well we who are supposed to
have 26 events this year tournaments and
what we call showcase events so they're
like super fight events but our
tournaments are for all jiu-jitsu
competitors any age gender experience
level and we have nine beneficiaries so
we're obviously in the cancer space so
this year we had nine
offici Aries that we support so we're
supporting everything from research to
to training both domestically and
internationally survivorship support as
well if we support a camp and Maine for
folks that are going through
life-threatening diseases so we sort of
run the whole gamut in how we support it
and we do it all through Brazilian
Jujitsu which I understand is sort of
niche but you know relevant to anyone is
even an MMA fan or but mostly yeah I
think um I apologize because I just want
to get to something more before I get
off here and I feel like we got the gist
there look I think back to reality like
I think you're smart enough to know two
things one they're not going to events
thing will run its course three months
six months there might even be a blip
again in the fall in winter if you're
listening to a lot of doctors there is a
belief that there'll be a period where
later this year in the winter it may
flare up a little bit more so there are
people even if everything gets at the
vaccine mode like one could argue that
live events will decline by 10 to 30
percent for the next 18 months minimum
ly coming from you know - I think you're
smart enough to realize that like you
know people potentially when the economy
gets tighter people donating is harder
people have you know they're worried
about their their immediate things their
charitable notice so I think you just
need to mentally wrap your head around
that bunkering down and again and you
know this was the advice of Kourtney's
at some level and it's the advice again
like this is a time for content brother
this is story time with JT like this is
like you putting out on I need is you
the reason it was so quick for me to
remember you was because you were such a
compelling story and guy and like I just
need you to make unlimited [ __ ] story
videos on Instagram tick tock and
YouTube cuz that's gonna lead to the
right one or my hope is that leads to
one or two whales that fall in love with
you because a hedge fund guy or gal are
sitting there bored right now they watch
a tick tock because they're 40 no got on
there you know and all of a sudden you
tell this story they're compelled by it
and they are in a place where they have
12 million dollars in the bank
and they become your whale content leads
to
opportunity there's a lot of things you
can't do right now the biggest thing you
can do is make confident scale at scale
at scale right yeah so we were gonna we
were gonna do a campfire story time with
with JT I'm sort of crafting it because
I do you know transparency is one of our
biggest pillars that we have for our
brand and and I want to be sir honest
about the realities that we're facing as
an organization I don't want to be doom
and gloom either I just but I want to be
you know honest and we you know all of
the registration and pretty much all the
fundraising has screeched to a halt but
we are still seeing people leave
fundraising so I want to help them in
some ways and and give them advice you
know I you you mentioned to call every
customer so you know I can start calling
all of our fundraisers who you know are
still moving in and what I would say to
you when you call your fundraisers only
call and say thank you thank you thank
you and how are you and is there
anything I can do for you
not a peep about asking for money I know
so it's great brother make content bro
please please tell stories please tell
15 stories about hey how you started it
that's the easiest one comic book number
one album that one always easy the
origin story but then tell stories you
know the closest you were to shutting it
down the time you got most bored with it
you want to be authentic talk about how
seven months ago you were actually
starting to get bored and actually
asking yourself there's such a young man
that you have other interests
potentially like like tell stories yeah
this is also one of the things I wanted
to touch on today is like there was a
time where I insisted I was never gonna
do this full-time you know I've been
worked in advertising I loved it fun I
was doing well you know we're hosting
just a few events the year and I felt
like I was making that difference and
I've told people I would never want to
go around the country and host dozens of
tournaments you know that's I didn't
want the carny lifestyle but here I am
now and I have employees and this is the
best job of my life and you know it's
you don't have to know exactly what
you're gonna do immediately and the ten
to two didn't
- doesn't have to lead to millions
either you can do something that creates
change I make less than I did in the
advertising world and you're a dozen
times happier a thousand I can go on
field trips with my kid whenever I want
and John's like that if if Corona leads
to 15,000 people choosing happiness over
money post corona then then there'll be
15,000 people positively impacted by
this like I hope more people choose
happiness I appreciate you brother we'll
talk soon
what do you got brother thanks Miriam
tomorry
thank you so much for talking about sell
stuff Saturday Gio who is Gio big up to
you real kids just changed your life you
had three followers now you have 28
you're about to get a lot more I just
retweeted told everybody to follow you
so that's gonna be fun to see what
happens
hello Marianne hi Gary how are you dude
here I'm doing well a lot of gratitude
for uh for this mass mass opportunity
here and so my question is around
leadership I feel very fortunate that my
husband and I have an automotive repair
shop we're in Connecticut or about an
hour away from New York City and we're
considered an essential business so our
team small team of nine is able to
actually come to work but focusing on
work is a challenge because of
everything that's out there and
everything that they're hearing even
though we've had meetings and we let
them know all of the things that we've
put into place and for you know a
sanitation and their protection or
customers protection you know with that
there's a lot of outside influences and
I want to ask you for tips on how to
help them not only for you know work but
once they leave they go home their
leaders I mean their leaders at home
with family with friends and how do they
get through that with you know that
negativity that they're hearing and
getting caught up in that um
you having a challenge that some of them
their friends and family are trying to
convince them not to go into work
because they're gonna get Corona because
that's what's happening with my dad's
wine but you know we're going through
this at Wine Library right now I've been
spending a lot of time with wine library
because thank God and we have a lot of
hourly employees where retail store we
are an essential business and we're and
we've closed the store even though we're
allowed to be open because I wanted the
employees to feel safer but we're
obviously doing the wine Tech's calm
Miriam do you drink wine yes you better
sign up for wine Tex calm I know you're
not signed up for my Tex calm don't hurt
my feelings so anyway we're running wine
Tex calm and those things but yet you
know some people have a wife or a
husband who's like overly watches the
news and thinks you just die if you get
you know and like has those pressures
well I'll tell you what we've done we've
closed the store even though we haven't
had to that's not an option for you
because there's not an internet
component
we've also told every employee if you we
are so proud and happy that were open
and capable of paying you if you choose
to not come in then you can choose to
not come in if your family or you are
overly scared whereas much you would say
this I assumed you were a small business
and we would have to freeze that
percentage of pay I don't know if yours
or hourly or salary you make you know
we're trying to hang on and pay for even
the people that are home as long as
possible but we've also been very
upfront with them that like in a week or
two we might not be able to do that and
so if you don't come that's amazing
you're more than welcome and if you come
you get paid but if you don't come you
can't get paid and and then obviously
now there's a two trillion dollar
stimulus package we'll see who gets
affected by those but we're basically
saying is we're not trying to trick or
guilt people into coming to work and if
all nine if I was your partner if all
nine of our employees didn't come in
then we'd be closed in that scenario you
know and and so like that is the that is
the most powerful way to approach it
there's also the realities of like if
all nine employees then chose out of
fear to not come in that within a month
you would be out of business and you've
got to communicate that to them as well
they may not have a job and the other
there's also this scenario you know what
I told my dad and bran I was like look
if nobody comes in
I'll come in to wine library and I'll
pack bottles I did it for a long time
I've bored anyway so like you know
there's all those kind of games so I
think that's what you need to think
about yeah no I think that's really
powerful I did go over that and did some
research as far as like the pay and
everything that would happen if they
choose that and then when they go home I
really wanted them to feel more
empowered so I think a few of them did
they they appreciated the become the
planning and the positive perspective
and I think this is a great opportunity
for me to share it because I started
another business really helping the the
trades people that are in the trades
because I think when all this is over as
a country we're gonna really have a
different perspective because a lot of
the people on the tray in the trades now
are really what's holding everything
together as far as the trucking and the
construction and all of that
we're considered essential and I think
it's just even a different viewpoint
from even parents to take you know if a
kid wants to do something like that you
know don't discourage them you know
instead of saying what do you want to do
that for I think it's a yeah I mean I
think look being proud of your sector to
your point is amazing and I think I
think I think that's absolutely right
III wouldn't over you know when you know
when somebody gets a is driving on a
highway and then the cop lights go on
and you get scared and you put both of
your hands on the wheel and then when
the car the cop car drives by you you
get so relieved and for another 7 to 15
minutes you keep both hands on the car
and you're 55 not 71 anymore but then
about 30 minutes later you didn't even
realize I've been kind of back to normal
I would just tell you to not be careful
but keep in mind Marianne that like it's
a meet and I love that your pride of
your sector like all that don't count on
America all of a sudden you know this by
July in August if everyone's back to
quarter for normal everything 99.9% are
going to be back to the normal thinking
we're not to have this surge appearance
saying you should become
function worker if you want to like
that's like that's just not the way it
actually works right but but to your
point I think that positivity optimism
and practicality right I think in the
framework of pop positivity optimism and
practicality and you need all three for
the right dynamic that's the right
dynamic because when you don't have
practicality and you're just piano then
you know just positive mean optimism
then you have the potential to be pod
positive optimistic and delusional which
leads to death you know
positivity optimism and practicality pop
that's game-changing and you're talking
about pop and I think leaning into more
of that matters but you have to be very
practical along with your optimism I
love that that's great yeah I think that
the answer your question in a very
literal way is by you being that leader
to them it's gonna bleed into them and
hopefully they'll then exude that to
their people but the reality is is
there's no other way than if they have
that DNA and you set the example
leadership is about examples if you do
it then you know Ron will take 4% of
that and combat it you know but it's not
about giving them it's almost like
everyone's in like propaganda versus
propaganda right it's like you giving
them four bullet points of how to combat
of why it's safe or what percentage of
people don't like that just doesn't work
it just doesn't the reality is
positivity practicality what that means
is like look let's really look at the
stats here all the things we're doing to
be safe and by the way like and then
practicality by the way if nobody comes
in and we and we aren't in business for
the next seven weeks we do not have the
cash flow to stay alive so I want you to
also think about unemployment and that's
real talk yeah and being practical I
think now's a time to where even as
small business owners what what do they
say like necessity is the mother of
invention right so a lot of things will
probably not even probably there are a
lot of things that should have been
consistent and people should have been
doing all along now it's forcing us to
do 3m Marion I'm getting 4,000 email
and diems of day saying I should have
listened to you the world is virtual
yeah I mean we've had our business for
20 years so when people were not
marketing during those difficult times
like 2008 2009 we went all-in and you
know it was scary you know as hacker but
we did it and the good thing is now
looking back it was like we were tough
top of mind at that time so try to you
know I try to convey that to other
business owners in my area you know I
mean changing the world is not but you
know locally supporting in my community
by the way changing Marion changing let
there be no confusion you changing the
perspective of one person is the same
exact thing that I might be doing and
changing the perspective that like all
you need it like that's why this has
worked for me I when I was one person
that was I feel the same way when one
person emailed me that I brought them
value as I do today when hundreds of
thousands do it's the same game it's one
person's enough Syrian on persons enough
yeah that's awesome
take care of me thank you thank you
you're welcome all right Justin let's
sneak we're gonna do one quick
rapid-fire because I need a few minutes
before my 11:00 a.m. so I'm gonna try
sneak something for 3-4 minutes let's
get it in who is it my quick question is
I'm in the clinical field right now and
I'm wanted transition into private
consulting startup clinics and stuff
like that I have over 15 years of
medical experience so what is the best
way for for me to transition into that
spot right now given the cordon bars I'm
the front lines right now so that's I'm
putting that back at the moment but you
know moving forward here in the next
couple of months I would like to so how
do you transition into this so Eddie
thank you so much for what you're doing
your bravery and heroism and so thank
you for being in the front lines of this
better and for that and the serendipity
of us being together instead of giving
you a top of the
funnel kind of general answer I'm going
to have you email me
it's Gary at vaynermedia and when this
is all over this summer I will get on a
meaningful phone call with you and my
team and we will completely create
something for you the kind of thing that
we normally sell for fifty thousand
bucks and build an infrastructure for
you to make that transition through
content which leads to opportunity
awesome do you understand what we just
did here yes sir
okay Gary at vaynermedia say you're
ready with the weird background bridge
in the background
don't [ __ ] drive and [ __ ] you
better pull over I'm actually letting
you go Gary a Boehner media we'll talk
soon see ya Arthur everybody another
great episode of tea with Gary B please
share this stream right now and tell
everybody if they missed it they should
watch the recordings of it I'm really
looking forward to tomorrow can't wait
to see you tomorrow morning it's
becoming our little ritual
I think selling selling stuff Saturday
has become a monster idea that we got
out of this I think some of my best
advice in my career came out of today
this is really working I'm really
enjoying it and it would mean the world
to me you don't even have a Twitter
account go create one cuz that's where I
can see it quick
it's Gary Vee there please follow me on
Twitter if you're on Instagram and
Facebook or please go there right now
please tweet at me and let me know what
you thought about today's session I know
there's 10,000 people that watch days so
please I expect at least it's
unbelievable when I ask I only get like
18 people if you enjoyed this if this
brought your value please it would mean
the world to me if you tweeted at me
right now and told me what you thought
and share it Excel or people watching
tomorrow I think about this is I'm at
the apex of my value giving and I think
we can help a lot of people I really do
and I really want people watching
tomorrow please send this link to all
your friends on email and Facebook and
tell them to join you tomorrow I saw
some clubs starting on little Facebook
groups
I mean text feeds to talk about me to
like people encouraging people to watch
us let's get this [ __ ] thing going I
love you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]